[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Dr John baloney show
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money go ahead and give
you a heads up uh it is uh for those of
you listening live you know this those
will be catching us later this is Monday
the day after Sunday Bloody Sunday when
the student loan payments began again
and uh if you've opened your checkbook
or you've opened your bank balance and
you've looked at it after having to
start paying your student loans again
you're one of 44 million Americans that
owe 1.7 trillion dollars uh you've had
an ouchy moment
and um hey we're here for you we
understand it's overwhelming it's
confusing uh it's anxiety producing and
uh we're going to help you with uh the
get out of debt thing and even the
anxiety Dr John deloney has a new book
coming out uh tomorrow is launch day it
is launch book launch week for us here
at Ramsey building a non-anxious Life by
Dr John deloney and um John we it comes
out tomorrow by the way and I'll go
ahead and give you the pitch if you
order today before midnight tonight that
is the official day right then at our
website at ramsesolutions.com you can
get the book for twenty dollars by the
way the average nonfiction book is 32.63
in America today
which shocked the crap out of me when I
heard the books have gone up that much
but since I actually know the cost of
these things going up and the cost of
paper going up I'm not shocked but it
still caught me off guard but ours isn't
ours is 20 through the night and you get
75 dollars in free bonus items including
the audiobook the e-book and one of
John's talks from Smart conference and
uh John this book is uh it's already I
think we've sold enough that it'll be
number one next week when the when the
list come out I'll be shocked if it's
not we've sold a bazillion of these
things out of the shoot here unless some
kind of weird statistical anomaly
happens it'll be a number one uh and the
reaction to it is matched with the need
in the marketplace there's a lot of
anxiety yeah it's everywhere um
everywhere we go from wealthy people to
those struggling to kids to adults to
um geriatric populations everybody's
wrestling with it yeah and the the
population that has a student loan debt
that just came to you man uh building
you know one of the six daily choices
that you teach folks to make in here to
get there is this idea of freedom and
that that goes the whole thing with the
freedom yeah right debt free right I'm
debt free and I'm stupid I got rid of
Sallie Mae and so I'm free that it
changes everything yeah there's also one
of the the first steps is choosing
reality and I remember back in July when
it came out and we started barking from
this microphone
here is your reality some of y'all
bought houses some of you bought cars
some of you signed up for memberships
whatever that you can no longer afford
because you thought the government was
going to take your your student loan
payments away like they told you and you
weren't stupid that's what they told you
and but here we are we were stupid you
believed the government well there's
that so start choosing reality now and
start making moves now
and just like we told people three years
ago hey they're not charging you
interest now is the perfect time to pay
these off was it one percent of people
chose that reality and now it's back
right so I want people who didn't choose
reality who continue to kick it and kick
it and kick it and then October 1st but
that's true of all areas of our life on
anxiety not just money that's right but
I want people to feel it this is what
your body's trying to tell you you're
not safe it's been telling you for the
last six months You're Not Safe that's
what that's what we're talking about
here and the quicker you can choose
reality and move from that whether it's
student loans whether it's your marriage
falling apart whether it's your kids
don't want to be in the same room with
you what your health whatever it is if
you keep avoiding reality your body's
gonna keep banging that alarm louder and
louder and louder to get your attention
that you're not okay yeah and so the
purpose of the book The Six daily
choices is not to do away with anxiety
it is to do away with the things that
cause anxiety because we live in such a
frenetic out of control chaotic world
that we've created an anxiety monster
it called our lives right I don't want
to live in a house without a smoke
detector that's silly I don't want to
work in a building without a smoke
detector that's dumb but I don't want it
going off 24 7 365. so this book is
really a book about finding the fires in
your house in your life and your
marriage in your health not find the
smoke detector not the smoke detectors
find the fires
inspector to quit by beeping is to have
no smoke that's exactly hello yeah you
can yell and scream at that little beep
in your car when you're uh
seat belt's not fastened and it just
beeps and beeps and beeps or you can
just fasten your seat belt right that's
what we're doing here we're going to
find the simple things that are in all
of our lives that we got to deal with
yeah health and healing belief
connection Freedom reality and the
freedom a portion of the subject of
freedom is this idea of being debt free
if if
you paid attention the last three years
about the student loan stuff because you
had a student loan payment to make
imagine a world where like whatever like
I don't I don't care what they're doing
because I don't owe anybody any money
that's what we're talking about that
sense of peace and that sense of and
that could be Jade warshaw took eight
years with her husband to pay it off
that could be John and Sheila deloney
that took multiple multiple years to pay
us off
um it could be that teacher that we
talked to in New York City when they got
locked down who was a teacher who paid
off in one year 166 figures just kept I
mean just worked 20 hours a day she said
I don't have anything else to do I can't
go anywhere I can't hang out through my
friends I'm gonna get these loans paid
off whatever your path is Imagine
sitting here right now on repayment day
I don't have anything to repay yeah I
already took care of it yeah I don't
have anxiety today because I don't have
a student loan but that's right if all
the inflation talk it's just really
annoying but I don't borrow money from
banks anyway so what do I don't care I
mean it just changes how you do
everything interest rates are driving me
crazy not me I don't know money yeah I
don't I don't have any money out there
interest rates went up again on
mortgages not mine exactly yeah and so
it's it's it sounds trite and it sounds
silly but this is this is freedom is
that that word piece you've been talking
about for 30 years well I mean
relationships our health
our spiritual walk our finances these
are all areas that you can make choices
in that limit the anxiety Bucket from
overflowing right that's right and uh
the daily choices are are key to this
whole thing and uh it doesn't mean
you're never going to have anxiety it
means you'll have less of it because
you'll have less problems causing the
alarm to go off the way I've I've gone
about describing this Dave is we all
brush our teeth twice a day
most of us George Campbell we don't know
for sure but most of us most of us he
brushes your teeth a lot um brush your
teeth twice a day and then over time you
don't have bad breath and over time
um you don't have cavities but if you
lean in to give your wife a kiss and she
goes ah your breath is bad then you know
you probably have a tooth infection now
I'm gonna go deal with it similarly I'm
gonna do these things on a regular basis
to become part of my life and once the
when I start feeling anxious I'm gonna
know my body's working just as it should
and it's going to lead me to where
there's there might be an issue yep
that's how it works boys and girls
building a non-anxious life comes out
tomorrow for those of you that have
pre-purchased it the tens of thousands
of you thank you we will be shipping
them tonight they'll be heading your
directions so they come out tomorrow
you'll start seeing them in bookstores
tomorrow Amazon those of you that
purchased it there it'll be shipped and
if you buy it by midnight tonight
building a non-anxious life it's twenty
dollars we're gonna throw in 75 worth of
additional items for re we're right you
to buy it before midnight if you're
listening to me take the bribe this
is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
Dr chandeloni Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
well we're doing something we've never
done on the Ramsey show we sent Jade
warshaw and Ken Coleman to Washington
D.C they've been up there for about the
last 48 hours with the student loans
restarting uh talking to the man on the
street and some women on the street and
some uh people that should be on the
street called Congressman no I'm kidding
and uh they're they learning about
um what's happening with the student
loans so what are you guys finding out
up there
well Dave thanks for having us on so we
spent yesterday the full day of moving
between Georgetown the campus talking to
a lot of students about their current
debt situation and then we moved to the
mall in between the Lincoln Memorial and
the Washington Monument and talk to so
many different people it was a lot of
fun and we heard I think one key theme
was that people really believe
collectively no matter how they vote or
what they believe in from a religious
standpoint the message was
tuition is too high it's going up too
quickly it's outsized and that was a
very interesting theme Jade I agree you
know and something else they knew
tuition was high but when we asked the
students so how much are you paying each
semester how much are you paying each
year when you come out of college how
much total debt do you think you'll have
and it was really interesting they kind
of seemed in a fog about how much debt
they were going to leave with
um one guy even said to us he said you
know I've got bigger fish to fry I've
got enough to worry about right now I'm
getting my MD you know I'll worry about
that you know when I get out of med
school and I thought oh my gosh he
estimated that he'd probably come out
with about three or four hundred
thousand dollars of dead Dave so that's
pretty crazy yeah and his starting
salary he thinks sixty thousand dollars
so uh it's that kind of story that was
pretty synonymous everybody thinks that
tuition has got to be addressed yeah so
tuition is too high but so um so they're
saying tuition is too high but they
don't know how much it is
that's right that's right Georgetown a
lot of these kids yeah well now it's
interesting that Georgetown obviously uh
we saw a pattern too where these
students were saying they didn't know
how much they actually were going to owe
because Mom and Dad took out the loans
or handled all the details so that was
kind of scary as well and there's
another piece to it Dave and John not
only do they believe that tuition was
too high everybody agreed that there's a
major problem here and we asked them
specifically well what do you think
about forgiveness you know Biden these
administrations offering forgiveness do
you think it's a good idea and here's
what I thought was really remarkable
they all thought hey it would be nice to
have forgiveness all of us would love
for somebody to come in and take care of
our debt but they all agreed that it was
kind of a selfish you know it was a
selfish want that ultimately it probably
wasn't best for people for the
government for people in large to offer
that forgiveness a because it's not fair
for everybody and B because of the tax
implication of burdening you know others
who maybe didn't even take out student
loans with the bill
is it what are they I struggle with the
cost part because it feels like yet
another way of passing the blame onto
somebody else and
um I can drive by a car dealership like
a Porsche dealership and the prices are
going to be expensive and the car is
worth the money I mean it's expensive
but it's up to me to be responsible it's
enough to know I can't afford a Porsche
so I'm gonna move on
um do any of those students that you met
with own the fact that they're going to
a school that they can't afford it even
how much it costs
well there's no question you make a very
good point John uh but I think it's
different between the student who wants
to go into social work who goes and gets
a really expensive degree and is only
making forty forty five thousand dollars
and then the med student that we talked
to there's only one way to get that Med
degree and medical school is crazy and
to give you real numbers because this is
a medical doctor only going to make 60k
well he's talking about the intern years
uh it's what he said as a cardiac
cardiac so yeah so he's got an intern
for three or four years but let me point
this out because John brings up a good
point but if we look at 2010 to 2022 the
cost of tuition Rose over 12 percent
each year when you had inflation only
moving up at about two and a half
percent so it is ridiculous these
college and universities keep raising
the price because they've got an
audience who just keeps getting the loan
the Federal Loan program and these
colleges and universities are colluding
that's a simple fact oh no question
about it if you cut the money off from
the student loans suddenly the price
increases would go away
but that goes back to Dave what you've
been saying for the last year which is
the student loan bailout program is
almost beside the point we deal with
that after you don't deal with the flood
without turning the faucet off first
right at first you got to deal with the
faucet and if they were serious about
helping young people and they were
serious about helping students and
serious about not saddling future
generations with trillions of dollars of
debt they would deal with that up front
instead of just you know bailing water
and letting it continue to run you can't
keep making the loans that's
intellectually dishonest when the when
you know when we're we got a crisis on
our hands of student loan Epic
Proportions here so uh did you run into
people whose loans are starting back
today
yes it's so funny that you mentioned
that we got the opportunity to talk to
several folks I talked to a girl her
name was Ariel and she was excited to
talk to her she had strong feelings
about student loans and forgiveness and
she was really banking Dave on
forgiveness from the Biden
Administration and when she didn't get
it you know she's been seeing her
interest pile up obviously since the
start of September and she told me she
said Jade I've already seen a thousand
dollars a crew in interest from
September 1st until today she said it's
the equivalent of three full payments
almost and she said it's blowing my mind
how quickly this interest is accruing
she's an edge she's an educator herself
and she's like I don't see a way out and
so you know I was able to talk to her I
said hey what if I told you that every
day you know several times a week on the
Ramsey show we hear people come in doing
their debt free scream they paid off
seventy thousand eighty thousand two
hundred twenty thousand whatever number
of debt people are doing it every day
they've just got to have the tools in
order to make it happen and honestly
they've got to believe that it can
happen and I feel like that's the
missing piece uh kin that we've seen and
when Jay asked her that she lit up there
was so much hope that just took over her
whole body it was a really cool moment
so um I'm curious in my mind there's 44
million people today that have a payment
due for the first time in three years uh
in many cases a large payment it's going
to take a chunk out are you is I feel
like it I don't know why I feel like
we're the only ones talking about this
like the like the typical person in
America is talking about it but I
haven't run into anybody in the media
that's gotten that today is a big
freaking deal economically societally
everything else are you running into
people are going my God what a mess
not really when we were on the college
campus it was interesting Ken on the
college campuses it's almost like
they're just in a blur they have no idea
this is happening I probably talked to
five different students who I said hey
do you understand the significance of
today I said you understand student
loans have been on pause for three years
they're finally starting back and they
were like I don't know what you're
talking about yeah that's right it's
business as usual Dave it's not a big
story because quite frankly it's so old
it's been around forever and I think the
American people have lost a lot of Hope
to where it's not a sensational story
anymore and that's what's really a crime
you know this has to be addressed from
the leadership level in Congress in the
white house it's a crime that they're
giving this money away to people who
can't afford it and then charging them
crazy interest this is not about helping
people get educated this is a hidden tax
on the American people in my opinion and
there's a little bit of onus can on the
parents in this situation because a lot
of the students we talk to they said
from their own mouth hey I think my
parents took out a loan I think they
signed for it I'm pretty sure sure
they're taking care of the bill and you
know to which I said hey you better have
that conversation and have it fast
because when it comes time to pay the
piper you need to know who's on the hook
well Jade you bring up a great Point
there's a million there's millions and
millions of parents that use the college
their kid got into to give themself a
pat on the back and to be able to tell
their friends in church and the
community instead of having a realistic
honest conversation about hey child what
do you actually want to do when you grow
up and what is the best path for you and
our family there they just want to run
and say hey my kid got into Georgetown
my kid's going to Georgetown that's
right forget the fact that it's going to
be 40 Years of paying that thing off
yeah what a mess well it's absolutely
right John yeah well Jade warshaw Ken
Coleman in Washington D.C reporting live
on the first day that the student loan
payments kicked back in officially as of
actually technically as of last night
but uh there you go and um man we're
starting to see some movement out there
in the marketplace and we thought we
wanted to be right on the front lines
thanks for hanging out with us guys
we'll check in with you next hour
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage John and Rachel are with
us and uh a special debt-free scream
because John's one of our newer team
members right that's right how long you
been with us I'm going on eight months
now okay wow good deal and tell
everybody what you do here at Ramsey I'm
on the K-12 renewal team for our Ramsey
Education team okay so K through 12
meaning our high school curriculum
that's right and you work with that team
making sure that high school students
get our high school curriculum around
America that's right very good stuff
well thank you good work good work all
right John and Rachel how much debt have
you paid off uh 50 000 in 13 months all
right eight months of it you were here
all right and I won't ask your income
because we don't do that since you're a
team member and I was going to have you
announce it to all of your friends all
the people that you work with will be
standing around right now and we're
going to tell them what your income is I
think think that'd be just tacky so we
don't do that but
congratulations okay so five months
before you got here where were you all
living uh right here in Nashville
Tennessee what got you started on this
five months before you came here well so
the really fun part of our story that I
think even the HR team got a big big
hoot out of is that when I asked
Rachel's dad who's here with us today
for uh his Blessing he was like
absolutely but the only thing that we
had to do was he said you just have to
go through FPU before you get married
and so I like him that kind of kicked
off the entire Journey for us and so as
soon as we got married and graduated it
was kind of time to be a gazelle and
time to get after it yeah so we
graduated in May of 2022 and then got
married in June and right after we got
back from like our honeymoon and
everything it was August of 2022 that we
started attacking all of it and and then
just a couple months later you go to
your father-in-law go hey uh FPU one
thing now hold my beer I'm going to work
there yeah exactly yeah I don't know who
was more excited if it was if it was my
wife him actually to start being here
not gonna lie I didn't just go through
FPU I'm going to work there I got a job
there okay that's cool I like that
that's fun very cool very cool so that
means Rachel you grew up a financial
peace baby I did yes um my parents went
through it in 2017
um and then they were inspired by like
they're still in their Journey they're
almost done as well
um and so they started teaching a
generation change like the uh wow yeah
they started teaching that at our church
at church yeah for the teenagers yeah so
I took that um with them when I was a
senior in high school and
um foundations and personal finance at
in high school as well which is cool
because now John tells that oh you you
couldn't get away yeah not at all so
you're stuck all the way around yeah
yeah John you didn't have a choice no
not really you're just getting to know
does that mean all the debt in your
marriage was yours no it was no it was
combined so I think it was about
um about June 16 and I had about 28. and
then we had some medical bills that
popped up over last year as well that we
were able to prepare for even even
paying off debt but um that was by far
one of the most stressful times was when
we just had a lot of moments where we
looked at each other more like just
tearful um and my my team member Ryan
Andrew can also attest like where I just
was like I'm so ready to be done with
this and so that that Journey that like
drive to just be to knock it out I mean
the pain is what really just gets you
going because you're like I'm done with
this so what kind of debts were those
student loans all student loans okay and
so uh yeah standing here today with
student loans kicking back in knowing
that's not there's a big relief
absolutely
yeah so you mentioned something that's
really important I think for couples to
understand there's that rah-rah moment
that really excited you have that first
conversation and we're gonna do this
and then there's month nine where it's
hard you wanna it's hard you're
exhausted you just want to go on a date
y'all been married one year can we go on
a date nope we gotta finish this this
journey you can go you just have to go
to the park that's right you gotta do
another free day another walk around
real creative yeah yeah and so but but
tell them what it feels like on the
other side like Dave just said student
loans are kicking off today and yeah
okay like for y'all it's not it's not an
event in your home right tell them what
it feels like to be on this side of it
it feels so good
um I think we talked about before this
what like the hardest part was for us
and it was definitely like going through
it and being like okay we're almost
there we're almost there but also seeing
like relationships and friendships
change because of our lifestyle change
um and at the same time like we had all
of these new friends like come alongside
us and support us in it
um and so yeah you got rid of the dumb
Friends you got smart ones we like
we
Dave they're watching too when they
climb like that we had a lot she's
trying to be so sweet will you please
list the dumb friends
[Music]
so many people come alongside of us and
like celebrate with us and like so many
are here today and watching everything
so it feels really good to like have
such a great Community around us
supporting us yeah I think one thing too
is uh
you know a lot of people who are living
life a different way and they're like
well that first year marriage is so fun
and you're like I don't know the first
year marriage really hard because like
we didn't live together there was other
things too it's like we had to learn how
to communicate not to mention and FPU
was such a big game changer here because
not only were we heading into this but
we also were going into this knowing
full well of like what conversations we
needed to have to start off and so we
already were talking about money we were
already talking about relationships
we're talking about where we going to
live and what's going to be financially
Savvy not where do we want to be but
where do we need to be and so even
making those budgetary decisions was a
game changer yeah you guys got a real
Head Start I mean there's so much you're
so functional it's amazing in a
dysfunctional world well and if you
think about if you think about it like a
sports team if the whole team gets
together and the first weekend they all
get together they just start playing
live games they're going to be terrible
they're not going to be good but you all
two spent the first year of your
marriage first year and a half yeah in
the weight room working hard right
working hard working hard working hard
learning to work together and now you've
got the next 60 years where nobody will
own you to yeah no not even Dave
nobody will own you two and y'all gonna
be able to do this I mean I do work here
remember
I used to also
um but nobody's gonna own you too and
y'all can make decisions about your
homes and your kids
so ever now John I'm curious uh did you
have much background on Financial Peace
University or anything before your
future father-in-law dumps this weird
request on you
um a little bit here and there I grew up
in Southern Illinois and so my parents
had kind of when he said that what did
you think tell the truth honestly I was
like whatever it takes wow yeah he could
have said well son you can marry my
daughter but I'm gonna set you on fire
he would be like okay I'll do that too
get the mattress exactly keep the
matches that's where I bring the guests
okay so it was that category it wasn't
like he's weird yeah I mean and too
they've been coordinators for a couple
years now so even we get to kind of
visit in on some of their classes as
well as we were kind of back and
forthman here in Cleveland Ohio and so
yeah even that part was really fun to
get to be a part of it even too is you
know we're looking for leaders here and
so how we can step into our communities
and continue to lead from a place of
accomplishing these tasks and then being
able to encourage other people to do the
same thing which I had my buddy who I
was his best man he came to me and he's
like well I've got this these like
credit cards that I use for school I've
got like ten thousand dollars and they
just got married and had like 60 Grand
liquid cash and I'm like dude what are
you doing I'm like pay off the dang
thing and so I'm sitting down with him
basically as his financial advisor and
I'm like this is what this looks like
it's really simple and it's going to
avoid a lot of heartbreak down the road
because you've got this now and when
Dave as you say when you invite Murphy
in bad things happen yeah I got a
feeling John's gonna be able to talk to
some schools into doing the curriculum
I'm literally ready to buy it right now
I'm thinking I'm thinking this is game
on right now well done you guys we're
very proud of you proud to have you on
the team and I love the Heritage and the
history and the whole thing it's a
beautiful story and uh
multi-generational uh financial piece
stuff going on here very good stuff I
love it I love it you're so set up to be
multi-millionaires and to be
unbelievably generous and help so many
people we're honored to have you guys on
our team people like you or who we want
we're going to give you the live and
give bundle as if you didn't have all
that stuff already with working here the
baby steps millionaires book The Total
Money Makeover book and a financial
peace membership you'll be able to give
those away to somebody in addition to
the things we already give you as a team
member to give away so you've got lots
of things good stuff good stuff John and
Rachel Franklin Tennessee members of the
Ramsey team members of the family fifty
thousand dollars paid off in 13 months
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
that's how it's done in the education
department I'm just saying this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and
remember hallow is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hallow.com
Ramsay today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
Dr chandeloni Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Shannon's in Columbus Ohio
hi Shannon welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you thank you so much sure what's
up uh I am 67 years old and I'm
wondering your opinion if I haven't
heard you talk about this on
pre-planning and prepaying for a funeral
[Music]
well it is a gift to your relatives
if you pre-plan
it's a gift to the funeral home if you
prepay
okay that was kind of my thought too
yeah because the inflation rate of
funerals is around four percent so
you're basically making four percent on
your money
okay okay and uh and you're of course
locked into everything but if you the
more detail the more nerdy and detailed
you want to get into it uh and I'm
feeling guilty right now because I've
done zero casket picking and I'm 63.
um but so I've not pre-planned or
prepaid in my case I probably actually
should go do some kind of a something
and give them a guideline because I'm so
pre-planned on every other part of my
estate plan it's so detailed and we have
meetings once a year to go over it and I
don't I haven't done the casket thing I
pre-planned my funeral to a t you did
and my wife made it very clear I'm not
running errands for you after she goes
this funeral will be how I want it to be
that's who I married yeah well Sharon
will be so upset when I'm gone she won't
be able to think clearly
thinking I bet your kids I bet your kids
have a casket it's a little bit of a
celebration
here would be my concern is that
the version of the funeral you have in
your mind that possibly you even prepay
for I would imagine there's two or three
leadership changes by the time
um you pass away and
what your family would actually get
would probably be less than what you
have in mind that would I would love I
honestly have not experienced that
honestly I mean it's a valid concern but
I've never run into that what I have run
into is I finally realized that the
funeral world is an industry and it's an
extremely profitable industry very much
so and like many things when you add the
uh financing or prepayment to it you add
to their profits I have figured that out
and that's true they make as much money
on the prepayment plans as they do
actual margin on the goods and services
associated with one being buried in your
final day so uh your final Arrangements
but yeah so uh yeah I think it'd be it's
it is a gift for people to not in a in
an emotional state have to make a bunch
of value decisions
okay that does make sense to me although
I'm being very uh upfront and admitting
I have not done that part of it I've
done everything else in the estate plan
and they'll figure it out probably this
Bunch will be able to afford it I can
tell you that but the uh but yeah I
would not prepay I've always told people
not to prepay and the extreme examples
are if you took the amount of a funeral
and invested at age 30 instead of making
four percent on your money you made an
investment return on your money you'd
have like 600 000 bucks when you get to
80. and so prepaying like in your 30s or
40s is mathematically ridiculous now
when you're 67 or 63 like me and you
then you know it's not as many years for
that to compound
you know even if it's 20 you know or or
whatever so yeah I I don't I tell people
don't prepay and I do tell them to
pre-plan that's the overall thing even
though that's one of the few areas I've
not done what I say to do what about
plots what about buying family plots or
I have not but I I'm not against them
okay I mean because you're purchasing
them yeah and what you're doing is
locking in the location and all that
kind of stuff and uh but I gotta tell
you uh if I had bought those
uh 25 years ago they're probably in a
different place than it would be today
so I mean um think about that where you
want to be buried 25 years now yeah I
mean think about how the city's changed
and the you know our lives have changed
and stuff in 20 or 25 years right think
about where you were you know 20 years
but you've been in Texas that's right
yeah no and now you live in Tennessee so
I mean I it's a interesting uh thing so
I I don't I have not avoided it I've
just not been
uh good and diligent well but I think I
think you've paid for your funeral right
I mean that's what an inheritance for
they got they can handle it I mean it's
a small funeral it's a small percentage
and it's not a big enough the the the uh
if if somebody's uh not left much of an
estate or no estate and then someone has
to pay for the funeral oh I've been in
those even more emotional yeah than if
it's uh if you're a multi-millionaire
and it's you know I don't know 15 000
bucks or whatever and you don't think
about it's a non-issue so it does take
the pressure off that way you could
really screw up a funeral in hours in
our situation and it wouldn't be a big
deal yeah I've sat with the folks who
are looking at me wide-eyed saying I
don't how much does a funeral cost and
you know and that's one of their first
questions that they're struggling and
there's no way they can come up with you
know five ten fifteen Grand whatever
they're going to charge it's a it's a
hard hard conversation yeah yeah so it
it is uh but what has happened is if the
way let me tell you who's a sucker for
it if you're out there if you've been
through the
while you're grieving having to go in
and select all this stuff and make all
these decisions
and you're not sure about the money
thing while on top of that uh then you
don't want your people you love to have
to do that on you so that's the people
who prepay because they want to they
want to never have that happen to the
people they love and so
um uh but but still I would pre-plan you
can do the exact same thing as prepaying
every detail if you wanted to right and
or that or you could just dictate I kind
of want the uh
the F-150 not the Bentley and not the
Smart car I mean it's a smart car yeah I
don't want the used Dodge Neon I don't
want the Bentley and uh somewhere around
the used F-150 level right that's kind
of what I'm thinking here so uh
some of you will get that and the rest
of you will be looking up the cars to
figure out what they are
you going to get one of those uh are you
gonna get like a an above ground
Monument Dave uh I'm not gonna be
getting anything
[Laughter]
I'm not going to be sharing sure not
spinning that I'm not gonna be I'll
guarantee you Sharon's not thinking
that's a bargain Kathy's in Boise hi
Kathy how are you
hi um so I'm a new listener to your show
um and so you may have already covered
this but I've heard how much you dislike
credit cards what do you do about rental
cars because I've tried to um rent it
without with just a debit card and they
wouldn't do it at all
okay it depends on the company Hertz and
uh Enterprise
will not Enterprise will at some
locations and not at others and so what
you've got to do is pre-plan your trip
and I can't tell you this you can't walk
up to the counter and get one in the
city you live in it's very difficult
uh to get to to rent a car that way uh
and so you gotta have a return ticket
you know so forth but if you're
traveling to another city yes there are
companies that will rent to you without
a debit card I haven't had a credit card
in 30 years now I rent cars uh today uh
we have corporate accounts they're not
credit cards I mean we have a company we
rent cars all over America because we're
traveling this you know I got a thousand
people working here so we have corporate
accounts and and they don't require a
card in those situations obviously so
that's an unfair advantage that you
don't have but I travel a lot right and
with like just doing family stuff and I
I just I don't have a problem I've had
one bad experience and hurts won't
period okay dollar will but it's very
difficultura will my experience with
Enterprise has been awesome my
experience of the time is fine yeah uh
just been awesome so I didn't know that
um I I would call around I remember I
won't I won't say the company but I I
sat there and I said
here's what I want to figure out I'm
trying to give you my money
and they were so difficult I could
figure out a way that you can take my
money from me and they wouldn't figure
it out yeah because they were working a
job they didn't care yeah that's it I
mean that's the situation with Hertz
they look at you all over the Blank
Stare like you lost your dad gum mind or
something but
um but that's the thing and we had
dollar with the Dollar Rent A Car Studio
here for a while they sponsored the
studio for a while and during that
regime uh after covert they all went
bankrupt or they all almost went
bankrupt and they turned over all their
leadership team that regime went back
and changed everything but we had
dollars set up to where they take a
debit card just like a credit card
Nationwide and we endorsed them for that
reason and gave them a lot of business
uh the new regime came in after covet
and the bankruptcy and the loss dollars
owned by Hertz okay and so they came
back in and the whole new marketing
people everything they went back said no
debit cards so we had to take the we had
to take the dollar we can't be endorsing
them we had to take the dollar around a
car Studio down so couldn't do it
anymore that's why we go
um in a fire customer it was painful but
um that's how it worked you know they
didn't renew because they didn't want to
be involved with somebody like us that
said only use debit cards never go to
Dollar never go to Hertz that'd be kind
of weird
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George Campbell Ramsay
personality co-host of the smart money
happy hour on the Ramsey networks and
the Georgia camel with a K YouTube
Sensational show and it's my co-host
today phone number here if you want to
talk is triple eight eight two five five
two two five or George Sunday Bloody
Sunday to quote YouTube U2 is uh has
come and gone the student loans as of
yesterday the payments are now due not
just the interest the freaking payment
it just got real it just got real it
just got really scary for some people
really confusing for some people the uh
the chickens have come home to roost as
they say and not in a good way not happy
for anybody that's in pain we're here to
help you the name of our company Ramsey
Solutions we believe in Solutions not
graping and carrying on uh and so one of
the things that we did is something
we've never done on this show in 30
years we actually uh have in the field
reporters correspondence
that's a big word
I wonder if they'll want extra money
they won't get it uh Ken Coleman knowing
shade warshaw Ramsey personalities are
in Washington D.C they've been talking
to college students at Georgetown people
on the street about the student loans
restarting and uh this hour Ken has
Congressman Andy Ogle's with us from our
district here in the state of Tennessee
Andy and I are friends and were before
he was an important Congressman now he's
a now he's a freshman Congressman up
there uh uh trying to do some good and
we're happy for that and uh so welcome
guys
yeah good to be with you Dave of course
we're in the shadow of the Capitol and
Congressman good to see you we're
thrilled to have you I know that you're
a limited government guy oh yeah you're
here to fix a lot of that you don't want
Congress hands in the pot too much
they've already created a big issue with
the student loan crisis with the federal
student loan program so with
Congressional oversight you know if all
the cabinets and of course the Secretary
of Education all that I'm curious what
can Congress do what should Congress do
about the free flow of student loans
well first let me say you know the less
government does the better you know I've
never seen a problem that government
can't make worse but that being said
we're in this problem because of
government so the question is what do
you do next and so like you said Dave
the payments are starting and then just
this Friday the Biden Administration has
put out there another 39 billion dollars
in forgiveness now that'll end up in
court and so but what they're doing is
they're setting these false expectations
to a problem that government again
created yeah absolutely so is the
responsibility of Congress should
Congress say let's lower the amount of
loans how would they do that what would
be a tactical way Congress could do that
well you know just thinking off the top
of my head you know you can structure it
much like say a state Voucher Program
would be is that you limit the number of
dollars per student so that's monies
that's guaranteed from the federal
government then you require universities
to put in so much a certain percentage
and so what you could do by that
mechanism is is really kind of slow the
increase in tuitions because look what's
happened over time is the more
guaranteed loans that you've had from
the federal government the more grants
from the federal government tuitions
have gone up exponentially and there's
no reason for these big universities
with billions of dollars in endowments
to help students because they're feeding
at the trough of government Andy Andy um
I'm curious you and I have talked about
this before uh just as a personal
conversation but never on the air
as a freshman Congressman up there I I
have the gift of cynicism so uh as I can
I can't imagine how difficult it is to
get that group of people to do anything
I I mean as a freshman Congressman how
do you do you feel there's any
possibility we stem the tide of these
student loans going out because I mean
the number of dollars is just flowing
right at 17 year olds is out of control
yeah and there's not I don't think a
full comprehension of what's the
long-term uh impact look if you're going
to be a doctor or an engineer or some of
these high income earners you know your
ability to pay that back is is
reasonable but if you're going into
sociology or a teacher and those are
noble professions and you you graduate
with two 250 000 worth of debt your
ability to to pay that off is near
impossible I mean you talk to Dad about
debt and income all of the time and and
so the government is complicit to really
putting people in a bad way and like you
said you know these payments started
today that bill is now due and uh
there's no going back from that
I'm curious Andy what would it take to
actually end the federal student loan
program Dave always says on the show if
it's so bad we need to forgive them why
do we continue this so what would it
take on the federal level to make this
go away
well kind of uh you know the idea of
cynicism making it go away at this point
in time would be probably near
impossible but I think we could put some
constraints on it start raining in those
dollars amounts and really look to the
universities to tap into some of their
endowments themselves now that's gonna
my phone is going to be blowing up
tomorrow from all these universities
because I'm telling them to spend their
endowments but that's what it's for
right you shouldn't count on the federal
government to pay your tuitions to pay
your bills and look we're a free market
Society we should be a free market
Society that's true for universities and
colleges and that's at a time when
enrollments are going down so again the
cost is becoming coming prohibitive for
so many folks all right now I'm friends
with Andy so I'm not really putting him
under the spot here but you said it's
probably not going to happen I tend to
agree but technically could the
president or is it a congressional
decision to wipe the program out is it a
vote
congressional action and again with
divided government divided government by
the way can be a good thing when it's
done with in a thoughtful manner right
now it's very partisan which is
unfortunate and so everything we do is
just is a gunfight but that being said
it should take it requires a vote of
Congress that's when when Biden tried to
forgive the loans before it ended up in
court the Supreme Court said no that you
can't do that and look the power of the
purse belongs to the House of
Representatives so we're the ones that
has to dial it back and like I said when
you look at all the problems whether
it's health care or Transportation or
student loans the government
unfortunately has a role in creating
those problems so what hearing Dave and
George is in order to get Congress to
dial it back we should start dialing the
hotline that's right start throwing some
people out putting some good people in
like Andy and take back our economy and
get rid of debt
so a couple of weeks into the your first
term are you more hopeful or is this
bigger bigger problem than you thought
it was serving up there
well it's an honor to serve you know
we're about nine months in now and you
know I you know we were talking offline
yeah 435 members of Congress and I'm not
disparaging anybody but there's really
about 40 that are the firewall from just
total spending Anarchy and social
Anarchy and of that 40 or 50 there's 20
of us that you know if you look at the
really tough votes the really
conservative uh votes I'm not bragging
but my name's always on that list and
I'm dragging the conference to the right
of saying look we've got to hold the
line here look I don't know you know I
know this isn't about immigration but
regardless of where you're at on that
policy we've got an issue at the
southern border wherever you are on
spending we have an issue with debt and
we've got to rein this in Period thanks
for being with us congressman and the
ogles uh representative of our district
here in Williamson County area in
Nashville uh Franklin area and Ken
Coleman serving as a correspondent yes
they're in Washington come true gotta
love it yeah he's right he's always
wanted to do that since it's true and
yeah Rachel wants to be a weather girl
and Ken wanted a D.C correspondent so
you make dreams make dreams come true
that's what we do here except the
weather part yeah this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today it is
book launch week around here Dr
chandeloni's brand new book building a
non-anxious life comes out tomorrow
Tuesday October the 3rd if you order it
today Monday October the 2nd by midnight
it's twenty dollars and we will throw in
75 dollars worth of extra goodies
including the e-book and the audiobook
it includes the nine daily choices to
deal with anxiety anxiety is very real
it's very real a lot of people deal with
it on different levels for different
reasons Dr John has addressed this in a
way that everyone can understand it and
there's actual reasonable Common Sense
Solutions not perfect and not MediCal
answers although sometimes they're
medical answers involved but this is
more of a a straightforward idea that is
scriptural and is also scientific and is
based in his um all the nine phds that
he has I'm exaggerating one reason you
get anxiety is if you're exaggerate but
so check it out building a non-anxious
life Dr chandeloney twenty dollars at
ramseysolutions.com Crystal is in
Houston hi Crystal welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hello hey what's up
oh okay so um I just kind of feel like
I'm drowning over my head kind of like
all your all your things say I feel all
those things um
we're gonna pay attractive paycheck and
not even making it doing that I've cut
out all the extra stuff
and so I kind of just I am lost and
running I'm sorry it's scary
so um what's your income
uh so I'm United then bring home
um between six and eight thousand
dollars a month depending on overtime
and that kind of stuff
what do you do for a living
uh I'm a nurse what about him
he works in the oil field okay all right
and uh how much debt have you gotten not
counting your home
not counting my home
um I've got about 55 56 000 in credit
cards and loans and then
my car I was right around 20 on it
and I've got student loans too but I'm
not even to the point where I can even
think about that yet
um what's the balance on your student
loans
uh it's 60 but you've been approved for
plan
well that's over 20. that's over 20 or
30 years so that's not a good plan but
for right now it's giving you a a good
low payment with no penalties and no
extra interest
so okay so the save plan is good for you
to Kick the Can down the road but it's
not good for you to actually pay off the
student loans you see the difference
right so at least it makes it manageable
for a short time while we address some
of these other things so 55 000 in
credit card debt
so you guys have been married you guys
have been married eight years
seven almost like I've done this before
yeah you got the seven year marks all
over you okay yes as of yesterday so
you've been saying hey I've got student
loaneda I've got this car alone is this
just your debt does he have debt as well
or is this household
mine two of the credit cards in his name
that total about 10 of the rest and the
house is in his name it's not in mine
okay is he feeling the weight of any of
this or are you kind of shouldering at
all have you told him I told her at all
he's got he's got horrible anxiety and
so for me to pitch it to him just makes
it worse
for you to just hold up a mirror he goes
I don't want to see it I don't want to
see it hey Scott stop stop he's got what
anxiety
he's got horrible anxiety he's working
with the doctor about but um okay it
just makes things worse to bring it to
him
okay
well
um
all right and so you need to know what
to do right
yeah I'm just I'm lost
and I'm doing all the things and I just
I'm drowning I don't know where to go
from here yeah you did a good thing with
the safe
and you did a good thing by calling so
you are taking action steps rather than
being completely paralyzed even though
you don't see a way out so that's the
first thing congratulations
a lot of people freeze like a deer in
the headlights and get run over by the
truck
yeah and not you you're dodging okay
you're Frogger you're in the middle of
the road going oh God okay oh God right
and so that's good so we can actually
help you because you're willing you're
you're actually willing to do some stuff
it sounds like okay so the first thing
is this let me let me see if this sounds
right
the two of you got married and life was
a party thank God it's Friday oh God
it's Monday and we've had a lot of fun
in the first four years of marriage
and then we hit the last three years
uh yeah well it wasn't exactly
oh okay the party okay different kind of
party but all right that's good chaos
chaos okay because what I smelled was
disorganization and life happening to
you instead of you happening to life for
seven years it's what your budget says
is what your debt says
yes life doesn't really happen to me and
um it says chaos and you probably use
the phrase well we had to and of course
yeah exactly we had to put it on the
card we had to take out the car loan
kids gotta eat I gotta buy shoes
and he's not helping he's got anxiety
I know
what I'm saying he doesn't help
me problem or the organization part
he goes and works and makes money uh but
that's it
right okay so uh all of that to say that
what caused this was money happening to
you instead of you happening to money so
we have to flip that on its head and you
become very proactive and you're going
to get extremely nerdy and organized and
every dollar is going to be under the
Whip and the chair like you're a lion
tamer
and you're going to make every one of
these dollars do a dance before it does
anything and anybody who comes anywhere
near your plan they're going to get the
evil eye from Mom
you're going to work your plan and
you're gonna we're gonna develop a plan
together and you're going to get an
attack mode
all right
okay it may involve selling the twenty
thousand dollar car
it probably does
what's the payment on that
600 yeah would 600 bucks really help if
you feed that up yeah definitely would
how much is your house payment
eighteen hundred that's not bad okay
you're good okay so what when you have a
detailed plan and every dollar is
behaving when you work extra overtime or
he does it feels good because you're
actually making traction towards getting
your life back knocking these debts out
rather than feeling like you do now
which is a rat and a wheel
yes you see the difference
yes okay now what we're going to do
George and I are going to put you
through Financial Peace University it's
our nine week class we're going to set
you up with every dollar budgeting app
the premium one as a part of the package
and that's going to connect to your bank
and help you put together a budget in
the class and we're going to show you
hand step by step by step how to get on
a budget how to get control of this
you're probably going to get the car
sold and get you a hooptie for a little
while not for the rest of your life
you're probably both working extra for a
while and I'll add one thing to it that
you're not going to like but you've got
to do it anyway
he's got he's got to emotionally stand
beside you his angs listen let me tell
you there's a truth in this anxiety is
not caused by bad news anxiety is caused
by no news and I know something bad's
out there
people that have anxiety can face the
actual fire that the fire alarm is going
off on what they have trouble facing is
ambivalence the lack of knowing what it
is like the boogeyman is out there and I
don't know which story is going to come
in but if we know where the boogeyman is
and exactly what he looks like and he
has a name your anxiety actually goes
down not up I'm not a psychologist but I
have been doing this for 35 years and
I've watched people's peace of mind go
up not when they got out of debt as much
as when they decided together to attack
the debt and so your husband gets to
help you not do the bills but he gets to
sit down with you and be a man and carry
his share of the weight of this problem
in your household the two of you need to
carry this together it is not fair for
you to carry it by yourself it is not
productive and it is not efficient for
you to carry it by yourself it is better
if the two of you do it together because
once he sees that if I work an extra two
hours I can get that credit card paid
off we're going to cut that puppy up
it's gone forever and if we keep this up
in 36 months and we sell the car we're
going to be a hundred percent debt free
student loan and everything once he sees
that he's not going to have anxiety
anxiety comes from a lack of hope not
hope through hard things there's a
difference
absolute difference this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45 off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May apply
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions we have the debt
free stage on the debt free stage Jamie
and Kyle are with us hey guys how are
you hi we're good how are you welcome
welcome where do you guys live we live
in Elizabethtown Kentucky oh just up the
road welcome to Nashville good to have
you and down here to do a debt free
scream how much have you paid off paid
off 158 000 and a little over five years
all right very good and your range of
income during that time we started at 55
and ended at 300 000. whoa what do you
all do for a living
um during the time when we started I
worked in the dental business on the
business side I'm now a stay-at-home mom
okay and I work for a wholesale
Automotive Group out of based out of
E-town Kentucky doing what uh just
wholesaling cars
oh okay all right all right yeah nice
job well done I like it I like it what
kind of debt was the 158 it was a car
loan student loans credit card and our
mortgage yeah
looking at weird people
paid for house how old are you two I'm
28. I'm 29. this is so weird not even 30
with a paid four house wow what's the
house worth I just looked about 235.
awesome excellent and how much in your
retirement nest eggs these days
uh uh let's say about 85 000 in
retirement perfect okay good so you're
on your way to being baby steps
millionaires by the time you're mid 30s
probably at this at the stroke well done
if you keep up this income with no debt
it's just gonna go we're very excited
it's incredible the numbers are good I
like it very good fun fun good stuff you
guys all right tell us what happened
five years ago how this journey start
and what happened
um we got married in June 2017 and we
yolo'd a lot uh our beginning of
marriage we just spent every penny that
we made honestly it was constantly going
out with friends whatnot
um we convinced ourselves to buy my to
buy me a new car and we convinced
ourselves to buy me a new car
I don't know who the car salesman is
here and
um I remember I called my mom one night
because I just happened to look up I was
like we're 30 000 a little over 30 000
in debt and I'd never borrowed a penny
in my life I took your class in high
school and until we got married I'd
really followed those principles I
called my mom I said I I can't breathe I
I really I felt like I was suffocating
and she said you know what to do tell
your husband what you know and see you
know what's gonna happen and I told Kyle
and he was immediately on board I think
he was really excited for the retirement
investing portion of it um but we got
started we worked our butts off we
drained our savings sold the car Kyle
picked up an umpiring gig I picked up a
waitressing gig three side jobs some
really I mean I was like scrubbing
toilets and dressing up like princesses
at kids birthday parties I was really
doing like not on the same day
okay sometimes I would be a princess in
the morning and scrub someone's toilet
that evening wow whatever
honestly we did it and that's pretty
cool and that was the Consumer Debt and
we followed the baby steps we got into
our house in 2019
two weeks later we found out we were
pregnant which was exciting but not
expected and then we just knew game on
we want to pay off this house as quick
as possible we had our Second Son
they're 13 months apart so we just kind
of had to keep reevaluating our game
plan and figure out how to readjust and
stay on track but but then as the income
shot up the car business took off yeah
it's easy to just reach over knock the
house out yeah covid this is the coveted
mortgage free deal here the coveted
babies and that was you know made it for
a bumpy road but it it's been a blessing
through it all we've learned a lot and I
was able to leave my job and raise my
babies which is awesome for me
um that's a great why and then for me it
was like
starting to stop being a kid time to
grow up because at the time when we
started I didn't have nothing in
retirement and I was like nobody else is
going to do it for me so I could do it
for myself yeah amen amen yeah there's
there's something that happens
particularly starting babies you're like
oh God this just got real oh yeah uh
it's a grown-up time now exactly we were
very much acting like kids at the
beginning of our marriage and we've
grown up a lot so wow well I'm glad you
caught it before you're 30. a lot of
people do that and they're 50 and they
go I can't live like a child anymore so
the fact that you guys have so much of
your life ahead of you with an amazing
income no payments how does that feel
we're very excited I think
um
for me it's just exciting to know that
there's so much opportunity available
for us and you know obviously we've
we feel great that we can you know buy
some new things and go on vacations and
whatnot but we've been able to give some
gifts above our tithe which has been
really a big blessing for us but just to
know that there's so many open doors you
know for us because we don't have that
strain of debt it's that's really
exciting for me so what's the first big
thing you do when you're 28 years old
and you're 100 debt free you're adults
and you're on a game plan but you just
gotta you gotta mark this somehow you
got to do something cool what are y'all
gonna do cool we've done a lot of cool
stuff uh we went to Vegas which was
something that we always wanted to see
it was really fun we got a new deck
that'll do we had to replace our HVAC
system
thank you adults real quick
do something cool when you say HVAC
system that's when you know you're old
yeah I went to Scotland on the golf trip
foreign is okay that's what I was
looking for we have celebrated a lot
this year you deserve it we I feel that
we do we live like no one else later you
get to live and give like no one else
yeah your baby steps seven you're 28
years old everything's paid for you
busted it from princesses to toilets to
whatever it took man I mean it's pretty
cool that's pretty important proud of
y'all well done thank you uh what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is you want to go first yeah I
would say uh just communicating if
you're married communicating with your
spouse and encouraging each other and
don't let um
because you're gonna have things Sayers
that try to pull you down and say I
can't do it it's not worth it you had
some of those I bet oh yeah yeah at the
beginning yeah yeah I would say work
which is weird for me because now I stay
home with my boys which is work but it's
a different type but like I said I mean
we just really we just dug in and we did
everything that we could to make a buck
and Save A Buck and don't look at what
other people are doing you know when or
saying or saying I think sometimes it's
hard for me because I I'm afraid if they
hear our income they might think it was
easy you know but we weren't making that
when we started and we never knew that
that would happen so actually that only
has come on in the last 18 to 24 months
exactly over the five years exactly
exactly so we started where we were we
had a goal and we were just determined
and we trusted God through the process
he's been a huge blessing to us to just
give us the ability to work every day
and to improve our lives in more way
than just finances but work your butt
off work your butt off especially while
you're young especially if you want the
energy to do it yeah well that's that's
where money comes from work absolutely
novel idea doesn't come from the
government sure and it doesn't come from
a hack of some kind of tick-tock hack it
comes from a work okay and you brought
the kiddos with you what are their names
and ages let's bring them up someone's
crying that's right we're trying to see
how this goes Weller's our youngest he's
two and Eli is three
there it is for all America to hear hi
all right what a sweetheart all right
very cool very cool Liv and hey guys we
got the live and give box for you so
baby steps Millionaire's book which is
your future great baby The Total Money
Makeover book and uh Financial Peace
University membership you can use those
or give them away all right James and
Jamie and Kyle Eli and Weller 158 000
paid off in five years making 55 to 300.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Music]
oh
you gotta love it
man family tree change just like that
yeah those boys their life has changed
they have no idea not only have they got
a mama knows about hard work raising
them that's good boy Mom right there and
uh but on top of that uh it's a family
that knows about doing that and that did
the did the thing did the sacrifice to
be able to win and you know how much
money you can get from 30 on when you
have no payments in the world it'll blow
your mind just popping that into an
investment calculator stick that in a
compound interest calculator your mind
will be
you can do a whole lot of giving saving
and spending with that wow and they'll
go back and watch us on YouTube 10 years
from now and they'll see what Mom and
Dad did that's the beauty of this show
that's exactly how it works this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host guys if you want to help us out
we need your help you can subscribe and
follow the show it changes everything
leave a five-star review it helps a
bunch and click the share button or
share the fact that you listen to this
show just tell somebody
or click a link and send it over it
helps a bunch if you do all of those
because it pushes the show forward in
the algorithms and causes people to
listen and then they can decide for
themselves if they like it or not some
do some don't our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services when you need to make
repairs schedule routine maintenance or
get local help for Home Improvement
projects the neighborly app is your
source to find and schedule reliable
home service providers in your area
download the neighborly app today
today's question comes from Grant in
Virginia we paused baby step two when
preparing for our baby to come and have
had trouble getting back on track how do
we get back on track when we're still
figuring out all of these new baby
expenses
oh my goodness okay so they did the
right thing we tell people hey the one
of the few times to pause your debt
snowball is storm or stork mode you got
a baby wait till mommy and baby are home
safe then continue the debt snowball
after you've saved up some money so now
so much better than the way I have said
it would you say storm or stork that's a
little alliteration going there that's
very good I only can think in tweets
Dave anything longer than that hurts my
brain apparently that one's great I like
it you can have it so we're talking
about getting back on track I I assume
you're doing an every dollar budget if
you're not that's the place I would
start because you're going to have your
income and your expenses and people
freak out when they have a baby Dave
because they go it's gonna be so much
money and then you go okay we're gonna
add a line item for diapers and a line
item for formula
um an old Boomer with grandkids and go
I'm not sure what the actual cost of
this small Critter is it's mental and
emotional
they don't eat much
and diapers are expensive formulas
expensive but not enough to it's not
like you took on a mortgage payment
I mean it's a small amount you have to
go see the pediatrician it's federal law
that's true and I'm kidding but you have
to pay their I used to say you have to
pay the pediatrician's Porsche payment
and I had a pediatrician go Dave do you
know what pediatricians make we're the
least paid in the medical profession I
didn't know that I didn't know that
either
I think they're underpaid I don't know
so but anyway so either way you got a
doctor bill or two you got um a little
bit of formula a little bit of diapers
what else is there it's not like the
electricity bill went up you know we had
the baby shower so we have all the gear
in the world but here's what we do we
get hand-me-downs from friends that have
already been through that phase and we
have so much stuff just from friends so
if you're not a part of a local church
get plugged into Community ask your
friends post on Facebook I would not be
buying all this baby stuff when you're
not going to use it for long so that's a
little money hack for you right there
yeah I guess it's like a lot of
categories in our life there's once and
there's needs okay the need is food
shelter clothing
diapers formula warm place to sleep okay
the want could be a fifty five thousand
dollar redo of the nursery yep or the
thousand dollar stroller which we may or
may not have bought Dave well that's
been that's been happening I I can I can
say that the Ramses might have
participated in this trend too but we
had the money yes and we're not calling
up somebody about your budget being
tight that's the key here that's
different so if you're calling up
somebody you're being tight buy the
thousand dollar stroller at a garage
sale for five bucks from the guy who
just went through the last kid and
doesn't have a friend to give it to
exactly and that's where these folks are
out they're in baby step two they're
trying to pay off the debt and so I
would be scrimping and borrowing and
scratching and clawing to not spend any
new money and for the things you do have
to spend on add a line item and then you
might have to sacrifice in other
categories hey we got to cut a
subscription it's not cut the gym
membership hundreds and hundreds of
dollars a month you know trouble getting
back on track
no you're just being lazy you shouldn't
have the mathematically trouble getting
back on track after a baby's bullcrap
that's what we're saying I'm calling BS
I think there's probably you're tired
emotional it's convenient spending
you're not sleeping much your brain may
not be working but mathematically the
babies don't make that big a dent you're
confirming my Boomer's suspicion yeah I
mean as far as what we have to buy on a
regular basis it's wipes diapers and
formula yeah and lots of all of that
because it goes in a lot comes out there
we go I am shocked to say the least
that's basically their job is to consume
and expel that's it they got one job
they're good at it right and so spoken
like a grandpa there I just hand them
back say I think this one's broken
there's something come there's kind of
an odor coming from this one I think
it's broken you need to fix it so that's
genius that's the beauty of being a
grandpa how many grand babies you got
now seven and uh no yeah and papa papa
Dave loves them I love the little babies
I just hand them back this one's hungry
I feed them times but I don't change
that no time for changing this one's
hungry this one smells bad and uh I
think you hand it back to Rachel Rachel
Daniel you all need to fix this I can't
do that to my wife Whitney Dave I think
I'd get it no I'm not getting back to my
wife either that's different that's a
different position in life I'm just
saying can't wait to be a granddad but
all of this to say the truth is all
joking and kidding aside I'm sitting
next to an expert who has a five week
five week old I was gonna say six yeah
five week almost six uh we have actual
case study here that the budget is not
busted mathematically by a newborn
okay uh Kerry is in Cincinnati hi Carrie
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi good afternoon how are you better
than I deserve what's up
well I am in baby step two
um I found you in February of this year
and the question that I have is
um I'd like to be able to retire without
a mortgage payment and in order to do
that I need to pay an additional 10
years off
um I have 17 years of work left so my
concern is or my question is rather if I
should put those additional 10 years in
baby step two because I'm concerned
about my ability to get my emergency
fund built up maximized by 401k and and
then make that happen with the mortgage
payments okay you don't have 10 years of
mortgage payments
you're stating this in a way that makes
makes me think you think there's
actually 120 of those payments that you
have to pay that's not true those
payments include interest that will not
be charged because you will pay it off
early so what you have is a payoff
balance you want to accelerate
correct okay so what is your current
principal balance if we were to pay the
mortgage off today
uh 248. okay and what's your household
income
uh 10 just about 103. good and how much
do you have in baby step two left
uh uh forty one thousand okay good so
and you made all this progress and you
got lots of traction and finally some
excitement back uh since just the first
of this year way to go good job Kerry
yeah I paid off I've paid off 18 000
since February 25th that gives me great
hope that the 40 is going away soon
right
six to seven days a week good for you
what do you do for a living
I'm an occupational therapist and you're
single
I am divorce okay cool good good for you
all right perfect I think we got a plan
here so the average person that takes
off with this stuff and is very
intentional and careful is typically
debt free and baby step two not counting
their house in 18 to 24 months you're
going to follow that model you'll be
done within 24 months okay
okay and then you build your emergency
fund and then you start putting 15 of
your income into retirement and then
typically what happens is they pay off
their home in the next seven years after
that so that model says that by the time
you're 60 your house would be paid off
on average normally following our stuff
which only involves twenty four thousand
dollars a year
so you'll probably actually be done
before your 60.
okay well that's great I'm terrible at
math so okay Sean I'm taking 248 000
divided by 10.
okay 24. okay okay 24 8. but we're not
really going to be working on in all of
10 so it's more like thirty thousand so
but um you can pay thirty thousand
dollars a year on this house or whatever
it ends up being yeah and be done by
then and of course what's going to
happen is your income's not going to
stay the same for a decade
right right so if you follow the baby
steps as is don't try to do multiple
things at once focus on your debt right
now it's going to be gone in less than a
year right
that's the plan then your emergency fund
is going to take probably another six
months or so
so we're talking 18 months you've got no
payments now we can start focusing on
investing paying off the house you're
going to do that in six or seven years
that puts this whole thing in under
eight or nine years to show you what
you're trying to pay off your balance
though it's not 10 years of payments
because you're going to save 10 or 15
years of interest on 200
000 that adds up that's a lot of money
that's not in this equation and I think
you were running the numbers that way
and this way is the truth and is a lot
faster also that puts this hour the
Ramsey Show in the books
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Dr chandeloni
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the Dr
John deloney show in the Ramsey networks
a very popular podcast on relationships
boundaries mental health is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
so um
Sunday Bloody Sunday the student loans
have started back John
yesterday for those of you listening on
a Monday October the 2nd the student
loan payments have restarted the
interest started the September the 1st
payments restart
October the 1st there have been three
reactions that we're reading about
oh crap
I'm up a creek
which is the proper reaction actually
the proper reaction would have been to
pay them off during the time that you
had no interest but of the people that
still have student loans oh crap I'm up
a creek uh I'm going to remain in denial
because I really think the government is
going to pay these off
or
I refuse to pay them
I'm in Rebellion that's a new one I've
started hearing yeah I'm this is unfair
the whole thing's unfair and I am
rebelling against the government and I'm
not going to repay them
which was is the most humorous of the
three as far as I'm concerned because
you you understand that they have your
social security number and you
understand that all of your tax returns
are going to go to them and you
understand that they know where you live
and you understand that the government
has almost unlimited power they can
garnish you your wages without even
taking you to court on your student
loans they don't even have to go through
due process I'm not sure that's
constitutional but they will garnish you
your butt without even asking you or the
courts I remember during uh kovid I got
your Rebellion look at my beer I got the
master I mean the the mystery check
deposited in my account
and I remember thinking uh oh if they
can put money just in my account they
could just take it out of my account
yeah there's a novel idea baby Yep
they're coming for you you got to pay
your bills man you gotta pay your bills
that's uh as our friend Les perrett says
ignoring something like this uh has a
high rate of Resurrection correct so
this stuff comes back to honk your butt
that's what happens so we uh did send uh
doctor not doctor Dr John deloney's with
me Dr Ken Coleman who's not a doctor and
Dr Jade warshaw who's not a doctor too
uh Washington DC to hang out and talk to
people there in um in in the area where
this all occurred where the disaster
originated uh called DC that's where the
student loan disaster originated and
they've been hanging out with both
students and uh grown humans and even a
congressman or two talking to them over
the last 24 hours hey guys welcome
hey thanks for having us having us here
Dave this has been
what's the word on the street
I think I want to add a fourth narrative
that we're hearing here which is there's
a problem we've made our bed now we've
got to lay in it and not only that but
what can we learn from it going forward
and you know Ken and I have talked to a
lot we talked to a couple uh of moms
yesterday who had kids that took out
student loans and their their degrees
did not Roi the way they thought they
would and so now the conversation is
honestly starting to shift towards what
are we going to do going forward to make
sure that more students don't end up in
this situation to end up you know to
where we can fix this for good even if
the government doesn't do their part
right yeah we've got to be talking to
the American people and we are at Ramsey
Solutions about avoidance you know
there's a cultural message uh Jade Dave
and John you guys all know this so well
that's been going on since the 70s that
said that a college degree was the best
way to success in some ways almost
guaranteeing success and the reality is
we know that it's about hard work and
great effort tremendous attitude that
helps you get ahead in your professional
life and so now we've got to be able to
ask ourselves is a college degree
necessary certainly if you're going to
be a doctor or a lawyer that's got to be
the path but as we see in today's world
you can have a wonderful career in
technology without ever darkening the
door of a college so there's two
questions that that we teach the
American people is college a degree the
only way to do that work that you want
to do or is it the best way meaning
giving you a clear advantage and if
that's the case then do it but if not
here's the great news we know this Jade
they're a whole lot less affordable ways
to get there and a whole lot less time
consuming so that's part of it we at
Ramsey Solutions Dave and John we want
to keep people from falling in the river
so let's stop that from happening and
that's really a big part of the student
loan crisis and not only that can but I
think what we're doing here on the
ground which is really pulling back the
veil and telling people a story real
people not just us you know sitting in
the studio having commentary about but
talking to real people
um I got to talk to a woman off the
Record yesterday and uh she was probably
I'm gonna guess in her 60s she started
with twelve thousand dollars of student
loans coming out of college and over the
last 20 25 years uh that has grown to a
hundred thousand dollars because she's
just continued to take whatever plan you
know the government would offer her to
have the lowest payment possible and I
think that that's really a picture of
what's taking place now obviously again
the government is offering these plans
and students are going yes this is great
maybe 20 25 even 30 years down the line
I'll have forgiveness but the young lady
or I should say the mother that I talked
to yesterday was a picture of how that
may not be the case and how such a small
balance can really grow into something
that's quite overwhelming
dealing with us up front John is
absolutely mandatory just taking it head
on yeah I mean I mean you mentioned it
it's what Dr Parrott says this stuff
will Circle back around on you and you
can wait and you can wait and you can
wait and you will end up paying what we
like to call a soul tax you're not going
to sleep your body would be failing you
to let you sleep your body would be
failing you if you let you have great
deep intimate close relationships while
it is terrified that the next shoe is
going to drop and so you're choosing 25
30 35 years
of
having a life without peace in it for 12
000 bucks that would have been a hard
year a hard year and John you knock them
out something some something I want to
add to that John is you know we're we're
seeing that yesterday when I talked to
Ariel you know a lot of people are
taking these plans thinking well there's
forgiveness that it says in the fine
print that the interest that is accrued
will be forgiven so a lot of folks are
thinking if it's going to be forgiven I
probably won't even see it accrue but
we're finding that no you will see that
interest accrue and John to your point
what that does emotionally to see your
bill go up by thousands of dollars every
month every year that's got away
incredibly heavy and for that reason
alone you know you should go ahead and
knock out these student loans not keep
them around in your life right can as a
pet for the next 20 30 years but hey
here's here's an important thing I think
that all of us just kind of had the veil
ripped off our eyes for the last several
years
if the government called and said hey I
got a plan for you I know you're over
your head here's a plan
my instant default setting and Dave you
might roll your eyes to this and call me
naive but my my default would have been
to trust not mine I think we all have to
realize the government does not have our
best interest at heart it has their best
interest at heart this is a money making
scheme for them and it keeps people
wrapped up for decade after decade after
decade pay these things off get them out
of your life once and for all and you
become the director of your life Jade
and can good work there in DC on the
street we'll see you when you get home
God bless safe travels this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host by the way guys our
award-winning documentary borrowed
future
about the absurdity of the entire
student loan epic failure is a is
available for free on YouTube uh you can
watch it other places and pay for it but
it's free on YouTube
so go go there and check it you can also
probably check it out on Ramsay
Solutions I imagine we've got it on the
website but uh either way a borrowed
future uh oddly enough
um Dr John deloney is one of the guests
on the documentary back when he was in
higher ed we interviewed him before he
was a Ramsey personality so that that's
um
you didn't know that was your interview
for the new position I did not know I
was I was it was a job interview you'll
have an uncanny way of interviewing you
without you knowing but I do think it's
without applying I do think it's
important to note
um
I mean when we look at what's happening
today
y'all called this back in 2019 when you
made the documentary y'all called it
this is we see the train coming and it's
going to hit us and it's on its way yep
for sure Kenzie is with us in Tacoma
Washington hi Kenzie how are you
Hi how are you better than I deserve how
can we help
my husband
and Anne
are
we've paid off all our debt at one point
and then I was stupid got back into it
um but we're like scorched Earth you
know really really on this plan to get
out of debt and one of the driving
forces is we want a cash flow our kids
college well and this is like the
perfect day listening to all of these um
these kids having or adults having to
pay for college again all their
all their stuff anyways um I have told
my kids I have a 21 19 and a 17 year old
girls and I've told them since they were
in middle school we will pay for college
but you have to live at home and you
have to go to a school that we approve
of you have to have good grades but we
will cash flow your school we're not
doing that we have been very transparent
about the struggle we've had with debt
the um the night you know the sleep that
we lost everything like that I did the
same thing I did the same thing except
they live at home park why do you why do
you add that do you have to live at home
um because if you I don't pay for other
people's rent so they're where I live
there are so many colleges within 20
minutes of our home
that there is no reason for you to not
live at home okay so it's your money and
those are your rules what's your
question
and go to school she wants to go to a
state school but she wants to go to WSU
which is over in Pullman which is six
hours away cool and they require you to
live on campus and that you have to have
the food program which is about
um 2500 to 4 000 a year so she's opting
out hold on she's up this is very simple
she's opting out of your out of your
rules she opted out yeah yes and it's
just it's very difficult for me
absolutely and I've dealt with
um my entire career has been spent
sitting with parents and you drew a hard
hard line a very hard line and you say
clear line very clear Line This is the
way this is going to be and she said
cool I'm going that way
and so the other side of a very clear
very firm hard line is other people can
say well then I don't want anything to
do with that boundary
and but that doesn't obligate you to pay
no doesn't mean you think it's none of
your money right
no like I said I would help with some
groceries no no no no it's none of your
money that's the rule you set up none of
your money yes yes no she opted out
wait it's like the the it kills me when
you see your kid running yeah it's
really is really heartbreaking to watch
people you love do stupid butt things
but you don't get to vote anymore once
they're adults
and the same is if your parents started
spending their money and they were in
their 80s and it's heartbreaking
um because they keep sending money
overseas to somebody who cares about
what I mean or your best friend buys a
hundred thousand dollars worth of crypto
because he's an idiot I mean you can't
stop him from doing the hardest things
is is when you love somebody they're
doing hard things that are you know are
not going to be good for
and so also if she signs up for all
these like all of these loans and things
because she has nothing saved she's not
doing she has to pay them back she's
making a choice I have to do I have no
you're not reliable paper you're not
liable don't sign anything I refuse to
participate in your Insanity I love you
too much to buy your cocaine you're an
addict
can
okay shocked it out shocked it out she
she thinks this reason we're being so
strong on this I know what she thinks
she thinks you're gonna give her money
anyway
and I can't I have two other girls that
doesn't she does she think that
she she does think that button like I
have to hold true because my oldest
moved out so we stopped school our
middle one is staying home we're paying
for school so we have to stay true to
what we say it's unfair to the other two
for you to not have integrity
correct zero help
now listen the one thing I have learned
and it is the heart I think it's the
hardest stage of parenting
is being apparent to people who are
grown up
because they're they're allowed to vote
now I can't tell them what to do anymore
I can't use my dad voice
it no longer works I can only use it on
the radio on a listener but I can't use
it on my kids
but uh that doesn't even work there
actually but uh you know I can't use my
dad voice anymore not even the dog
listens to my dad voice anymore it's
just gone I lost my dad voice it goes
you know I have to use persuasion with
everyone now
and so my grown kids get the exact same
approach when I disagree with them that
one of my good friends would get
I either just stand back and watch and
hold my nose
or I sit down beside them and I go you
know I love you
and I've got some ideas here of some
dumb things I've done in the past and it
kind of looks like some of the stuff
you're thinking about doing
uh would you like some advice from an
older wiser friend
if you say no then I have to shut up but
if you say yes I'll give it to you and
you have to go out you know like I've
got a friend you know I've Got Friends
my age who have grown kids that are in
their 30s and 40s one of them called us
the other day and said hey we have
teenagers you raised three great kids
can we take you to dinner we want to ask
you how to do that so I have to use the
but what I told them was persuasion I
didn't get to tell them what to do right
they ask and I get to tell them what I
thought and but that's how you get
that's how John persuades me or I
persuade John same thing that's all you
can do but you might want to try that
because I got a feeling in your
frustration you've used your mom voice
oh absolutely and your kids your kids
called your kids called your bluff right
yes yeah and I've been working really
hard on not talking at them but talking
with them did you say there's just three
girls
I have three girls yes where's Dad in
this conversation
so he is he's he backs me up we're into
different like we're almost out of our
debt and so he's like he's kind of
weighing like okay maybe we we do this
and I said no we have to hold we have to
hold her that's that's what I mean yeah
that's exactly what I mean so I want him
to come around front of this instead of
you yeah and I wanted to take his
daughter to coffee and say baby doll I
love you
and I as somebody who loves you not as
your dad I think you're making a mistake
here and I want you to rethink it
and I also want to I want to challenge
you on something too
and not on this particular one but I'm
challenging the the Bedrock that you've
anchored into
one of the greatest gifts a parent can
give their kids sometimes
is to say the words I went about this
the wrong way
not not the thing is wrong but I went
about it the wrong way I don't think
this is wise it like I want to take you
to coffee and say hey let me walk you
through while I'm making this this
choice because I'll tell you this you
and everybody can disagree with me
that's fine but after working in
colleges for 20 years four different
ones across a couple of states and
Consulting in a gajillion more if my
kids decide to go to college one of my
rules is you have to live on campus
Because I want them to experience a
bunch of different people and learn
about how other people do life that's
different that's a different philosophy
but here's the deal your kid is going to
say I'm gonna go for this one then so
you said a set of rules great either
live and die by it but I want you I want
Dad to spend some time talking about why
well I yeah why I actually want mom and
dad to sit down and say okay do we
actually both believe this okay and then
once it sounds like Mom made a line and
Dad's just going along with it but why
but why stick with it that's right you
gotta talk to a teenager you gotta talk
to a grown child as a grown sibling a
grain from a child is what it is we have
oxymoron as an equal and I don't know
why yeah here's why I believe this is
why I'm trying to talk you into it this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions I'm the
debt-free stage Eric and Madison are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you doing well thank you welcome
welcome where do you all live
Dayton Ohio oh good good to have you in
Nashville how much data have you paid
off sixty six thousand and twenty six
dollars good how long did this take two
and a half years good for you and your
range of income during that time 90 000
to 105. very good what do you all do for
a living I'm a teacher
and I'm a warehouse operations manager
okay very good 66 in two years y'all are
cooking way to go what kind of debt was
that uh normal credit cards car loans
student loans oh wow nine credit cards
to be specific okay so 33 000 bucks a
year basically or thirty thousand a year
roughly a little more than that a little
more than that but we'll get there okay
all right so uh what started all this
two and a half years ago well I uh was
in a hospital bed with some
complications from covid and uh the
entire time I'm laying there and
thinking how am I going to pay for this
because her credit cards are maxed out
this was before we were even married
um her credit cards are maxed out I'm
laying there not knowing how we're gonna
pay for it and it gets to you know we
get the bill and it was only like 300
but we couldn't cover it so I had to ask
my parents for help to cover a 300
medical bill
and then I thought back to a high school
class I took where the teacher was
giving us a
a lesson about your program and you
showed us a video of it and
16 year old Eric was like yeah I'm not
going to listen to a guy who went
bankrupt I want to pay attention to that
guy and
my memory after that hospital visit came
back to that and I looked you up and
found a couple videos and launched from
there and then I took it home to Maddie
and she was a little uh reserved at
first but eventually I managed to drag
her along and get her going yeah I mean
like who wants to listen to Guys Without
bankruptcy come on Eric so how long you
all been married
coming up on two years okay all right so
you started this right before you got
married finished it up after you're
married yes yeah well done good good who
is the person in your relationship who
loved them some credit cards oh yeah so
usually when you have nine somebody has
has a relationship with them tell me
about them yeah so I am a teacher and I
taught in inner city in Cincinnati right
out of college and you don't make a
paycheck for six weeks which no one told
me oh there's a nice piece of
information sure for sure so I moved to
Cincinnati had rant didn't have money
needed groceries didn't have money
someone ran into me had to get a car
didn't have money
um so one thing led to another
um my dad was like I already helped you
through college I'm not giving you any
more money
um and so you know a few credit cards
later
um there I was yeah okay and then Along
Comes Eric and watched this guy in high
school yes yeah and and by the way he
was laying in a hospital bed during
covert doing nothing and yeah but yeah
he's got a lot of opinions but but he
had his all right what I'm doing is not
working maybe somebody else has a plan
yeah and we definitely
um he dragged me for a little bit
because I mean I was I was a little deep
and by the time we you know started
doing it and
um working through it and um by the time
we were married we cash flowed our
wedding in our honeymoon hey and we um
cash flowed
um the birth of George and then also he
had a NICU stay so we were able to cash
flow all of that wow so in addition to
our debt that we paid off we also cash
flowed a wedding a Disney honeymoon and
also a nicuse day so wow so it was a
grand total of 93 000. okay oh my gosh
yeah there's a lot going on there you
guys have been very diligent then real
tight budget to make all that happen in
that period of time yeah a lot of no's a
lot of those mostly mostly from me yeah
it's the ancient word so the uh so so
you guys decided to plug back in or you
decided after High School plug back into
us well where did you find us how did
you get back plugged in uh I just looked
you up on YouTube oh YouTube okay yep
all right that'll do it absolutely so
when you didn't want to be dragged
Kicking and Screaming but here we were
was it the shame that I've got nine
credit cards and a lot of stats mine or
was it
YOLO like I wanna I wanna do what I want
to do it was definitely part of the
shame
um it was definitely that like it was
the norm in my dad's side of the family
to have cards and um several of them
um I grew up
um not in the most traditional way
because my parents were separated so I
lived two different ways
um so you know it was one of those
things where I was like okay what they
did didn't work and how can we make sure
that our family is set up for success
that's such a magical transition when
you can say hey uh
okay this path that I want to take
hasn't worked maybe there's got to be
another one right yes and what was what
was your most challenging marital moment
currently
um we don't actually live together right
now
um we are kind of like married people
that are dating
um which everyone looks at us like we're
crazy
um we our lease was up this summer and
we thought we'd buy a house we tried I
had a ton wrong with it so we backed out
before we got too far in and
um we have all of our stuff at his
parents and at my grandmother's during
the week I live in Kettering with my
grandmother and my mom watches our son
and then I commute to work about half an
hour and then during the week Eric Works
two jobs and lives with his parents and
then on the weekends we reconvene at his
parents house and then come Sunday night
we do it all over again wow when does
this end um hopefully May hopefully okay
wow that's the Hope because we're
wanting a house and the market is insane
and what we have right now just isn't
going to Warrant us a home that
um is going to be what we want to raise
our children in so yeah working in two
different cities we actually work
we've worked about 10 minutes away from
each other okay but she's living 45
minutes away yeah at her grandma's wow
wow yeah so it's definitely
um something that people look at us like
we're crazy but it's a lot of cash it's
a lot of them it's a lot of money that
we're saving between not having right
Eric working multiple jobs I'm a teacher
I've been a tutor I've been a nanny I've
been a babysitter I've coached I've done
all of it
um and so it was kind of Eric's turn to
have a second job because I've always
had two or three
okay that works it's not the best
statement but what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt-ish do it
following the budget and making sure
that everything's mapped out we sit down
and look at our whole calendar to map
out the events that we have George turns
one this October so we you know had to
budget for him to have a party and
things like that that um I think people
let them sneak up on them and we've had
a fun for his birthday since the first
of the year so we I have money ready for
us there we go very good stuff you guys
proud of y'all congratulations very well
done who was cheering you along uh
mostly her mom Jane she's with the baby
somewhere around somewhere she she was
cheering us all along the entire time my
parents as well were supportive they my
family doesn't really fully understand
it but we'll we'll give them an update
and they're very supportive of it okay
cool all right and you want George in
the debt-free screen oh for sure he's
going to join us how old is George he
will be one in October oh yeah way to go
a little debt free dude well done and
he's happy about it too I like it
hey we've got the baby steps
millionaires book for you Total Money
Makeover book and the financial peace
membership that's the live and give box
you all live some of it give some of it
George is ready man I like it Eric and
Madison and George Dayton Ohio 66 000
really about 90 000 paid off and cash
flow it included two and a half years
making 90 to 105 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
I'm like what happened
hahaha
oh that's fun his family tree has
changed his mom and dad got weird
they decided they weren't going to be
normal that face was worth the price of
admission right there that was fantastic
fabulous something about
um they mentioned it a couple of times
if I can't convince you on the merits of
an idea if I can't convince you on the
math if I can't convince you on the
values
if you're laying in a hospital bed and
you can't come up with 300 bucks can you
at least say okay this isn't working
yeah what you're trying is not working
would you try something else yeah
um so many couples like I'm not doing
that I don't okay is this working can we
just ask that question I think if more
people ask that question they would
humble themselves and go okay I didn't
try something else that's good Dr Phil
moment how's that working for you how's
that working for you that's right
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Psalm 37 40 and
the Lord shall help them and deliver
them he shall deliver them from the
wicked and save them because they trust
in him
Ronald Reagan said the most terrifying
words in the English language are
I'm from the government and I'm here to
help
I think we're referencing the old uh Joe
Biden debt forgiveness program here that
the Supreme Court said he's not allowed
to do which he's a lawyer he already
knew that has to be an act of Congress
you don't get to control spending when
you're the president it has to go
through Congress that's how that works
sorry about that the Supreme Court
caught up and now you guys have to pay
your payment
ouch but we're here to help you any way
we can that's what we're doing tomorrow
in the next few hours actually the sale
will end the pre-sale will end on John
deloney's brand new book because it
comes out tomorrow uh for those of you
listening live uh you know that this is
October the 2nd and um
October 3rd's launch day so that's
Monday or Tuesday right so Monday if you
go by midnight tonight to
ramseysolutions.com you can still get
building a non-anxious life for twenty
dollars and get the ebook the audiobook
and his talk instantly uh smoke fire and
freedom all of them will come to you uh
tomorrow well we'll ship them tomorrow
anyway they'll start getting the stuff
by email and the links and the down
links and so forth till then so hey
check it out it is the time to get this
book it is the last chance for you to
get it with all of the assets and um
John
well we've kind of been talking
throughout the three-hour program today
about the student loans restarting and
the anxiety around that but there is a
whole lot of different categories of
anxiety that are just running rampant in
our culture today and I guess it's the
different sources of the anxiety
well there's different sources right
that could be work related
um it could be relationship related it
can be Finance related it can be any
number of things calendar related stuff
related
um but I think much of that difference
has more to do with
how you were raised the stories you were
told growing up your genetics I think
there's a cocktail there so the way I
like to explain it is if you and I have
a house with a basement in it and your
basement is full of motorcycle repair
gear and in my basement it's full of a
candle making shop and I make candles a
fire might send your house to explode
and a fire might burn mine to the ground
and it would just melt gently right the
same fire would cause two different
reactions in our houses based on
you know our genetics the based on what
the way we're raised the tools we have
in our toolkit to deal with it and so
some people may struggle with social
anxiety some people may struggle just
they just feel anxious all the time some
people might gear up and want to fight
everybody and some people want to
withdrawal and so I think one of the
challenges is we've created this
diagnostic culture that wants to label
all those individual things I just want
to look at a fire right let's deal with
the fire it is important for researchers
to dig into those basements and figure
that stuff out but I for most of us need
on a regular basis to deal with the fire
part of that equation and all of us can
deal with the fire part so George and I
had a caller that said um
I can't I have to deal with all the
money issues because my husband has
anxiety false
and um I told her uh you you need to
correct me you can do it in front of
everybody but I told her that him not
being involved and taking control
proactively with her of the whole
situation was increasing his anxiety 100
that if he has if he gets anxious around
money
for some reason and we could pull it
apart for a couple of years his body has
put a GPS pin in money and it sets off
his alarm system
and every time he avoids it every time
she takes it from him his body actually
wins he got what it wanted which was not
to be around that threat so it
reinforces that thing and makes it
stronger and if he tries to lean in on
his own it will it will ring louder and
louder and louder and louder and so the
challenge with anxiety is the only way
to heal from it is through it you got to
go through it you got to deal with the
end and when you sit down with a
therapist to get over
um something you're anxious about that's
one of the most tried and true things
you can heal from
If You're Going Through Hell keep going
yeah it's exposure therapy they're going
to walk you through it step by step
until your body quits reacting to it and
then you got to deal with the actual
issues but yeah you're right every time
she takes it from him
um his body goes ah well my case was and
I don't know if this was correct but my
case to her was ambivalence is more
stress inducing than knowledge of an
actual boogeyman's details it could be
it could be but what I don't want her to
do is to run and be like you got to do
the budget now I'm out no no no I didn't
do that no no it is she's got no no I'm
not saying I don't want that to be her
response no I didn't know uh because I
because people here's the deal anxiety
is real man and I got buried by it it's
powerful and often it's when they I
don't want people to walk away what I'm
saying is oh it's just an alarm just get
over it just go through it that's not
how that works
um sometimes you got to get somebody to
hold your hand and walk through it
sometimes you got to get a team of
people and say I got your front and I
got your back and I got your sides let's
go do this thing and but you've got to
make your way through it but the fact
that the in their case the uh the
financial problems are stacking up
they're getting worse and there's no
light at the end of the tunnel that's
not an oncoming train he's got to know
that down in his soul just walking into
the house his amygdala knows that that
home's not safe their finances aren't
safe you can smell it in the air and I
promise you that that level of
um challenge going on there's something
else going on in the relationship
there's something else on the foundation
of that home that is causing it to lean
over well he's working on the oil field
he's just going to work getting a check
going to work getting a check going to
work getting just good old boy yeah
and working his butt off probably
absolutely probably a great guy yep but
she's carrying all the emotional weight
and strain of the household yes and the
lie that a guy like that's told is
emotions are for her you're you were
made for shovel and you all get out and
both of you have to shoulder both of
those loads and we're finding out now
okay I didn't have I don't have a tool
kit for sitting with my wife's emotions
and feelings I don't have a toolkit for
saying what I feel out loud I need to
learn that she doesn't have a maybe
doesn't have a tool kit for this level
of work he's putting in she's gonna have
to learn that so that's the work they've
got to do yeah but someone told him
along the way if he just says I've got
anxiety I can't look at it then that
gets him out of it and it probably has
gotten him out of everything growing up
because we have a culture that says if
you have a thing we're going to give you
a pass we're going to make the path
easier for you we're to clear the deck
for you we're going to go into the
weight room take all the weight off the
bar and that will keep your muscles from
hurting and that actually works it does
but nobody gets any stronger you never
find out what you could do you ever find
out how far or you could take this thing
how deep your relationships could be how
healthy and well and whole you and
grandkids you'll never meet could be
because we cleared the path so far for
each other now we got to change the way
we address some of these problems in our
culture well I got on my hand
um hands are just messing with it I've
got calluses from cutting trees and
fooling with stuff this weekend that
really an old man shouldn't be doing but
I did it anyway had a lot of fun with it
chainsaws are fun and so uh but that
comes from the stress yeah of the
physical stress in that case of holding
that thing while it's vibrating going
through it and when you first hold it
and you hit into that tree and you
forget that first Kickback yeah it hurts
and your body says hey let's put this
down but if you keep going
you keep going you keep going tremendous
sense of satisfaction you get stronger
you solve a problem you get the calluses
and then the next time it's a toughening
yeah it is what it is it's fire it's
it's a Refinery for refining process
it's iron sharpens iron yeah that's
powerful that is part of the whole
process you're going to enjoy this new
book building a non-anxious life uh by
this time next week we'll be close to
announcing it as a number one bestseller
I'm sure our sales and pre-sale have
been astronomical thank you guys for
your response to Dr John to this book to
his podcast uh to the first book which
was a number one bestseller we
appreciate that on your past change your
future was his debut and it was a number
one uh this book is incredible the six
daily choices to prepare your life build
your life in such a way that when uh
some anxiety comes when some stress
comes when a chance to toughen you're
toughened up you're ready you've got
some things you got your glass full so
to speak uh and you're ready to fight
you're ready push through the life when
it comes at you it changes everything
that's right and
if you're like me you don't have the you
didn't have the tools when your body
started reacting this way and this is
this this is a tool kit man it's a tool
kit it's a road map for how to live a
better life for you for your family and
for grandkids that you may never meet
building a non-anxious life tomorrow's
launch day if you want the deal go to
ramsaysolutions.com 20 including 75
worth of add-ons till midnight tonight
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
and the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
all right
[Music]